schauen wir an die deutsche grenze die
krise um illegale flüchtlinge und
grenzkontrollen spitzt sich derzeit zu
die zahl der migranten steigen als
100.000 flüchtlinge haben das neunte
jahr in folge asylanträge bei uns
gestellt bei nacht und kälte kommen sie
an heimlich oft über die offene grenze
aus polen
flüchtlinge in den wäldern von
brandenburg bei nacht und kälte kommen
sie an heimlich über die offene grenze
aus polen schuld ist lukaschenko
der machthaber von belarus er lässt
tausende migranten einfliegen lud sie
zur eu außengrenze von wo aus sie über
polen dann nach deutschland kommen auf
der neuen migranten route sind nach
angaben der bundespolizei seit august
bereits mehr als 4300 menschen unerlaubt
nach deutschland eingereist
vorrangig iraker und iraner außerdem
brisant hunderte vielleicht tausende
migranten werden zwischen den grenzen
von polen um belarus festgehalten polen
gibt selbst an tausende an der einreise
in das land gehindert zu haben viele von
ihnen harren seit wochen bei nacht
eisigen temperaturen im grenzgebiet aus
dürfen wir da vor noch zurück
der vorsitzende der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft heiko teggatz
bei innenminister horst seehofer alarm
in einem schreiben an seehofer da drängt
er auf die einführung von temporären
grenzkontrollen nach polen seehofer
reagiert auch sofort nach bild
informationen will der innenminister das
thema morgen ins kabinett einbringen und
dann schnelle entscheidung herbeiführen
bereits in den vergangenen wochen hatte
seehofer ja mit der bundespolizei
führung gesprochen inwiefern
grenzkontrollen überhaupt machbar sind
damit könnte also der grenzstreit
zwischen merkel und seehofer wieder
aufladen den wir schon
2015 hatten unter dem cdu und csu damals
fast auseinandergebrochen werden bei uns
zu gast im studio ist jetzt bild vize
paul ronzheimer abholt oder im herbst
viele flüchtlinge begleitet guten morgen
grenzkontrollen glaubst du dass es der
richtige weg
ich glaube dass grenzkontrollen
insbesondere dort wo sie passieren
sollen also zwischen polen und
deutschland der richtige weg sind denn
wir müssen ja erst einmal feststellen
wie viele menschen wollen überhaupt nach
deutschland
wenn wir das nicht sehen wenn wir das
nicht ermitteln können dann können wir
auch nicht sagen wie groß das problem
ist von daher verstehe ich die forderung
der bundespolizei denn die stehen ja
unter druck die müssen irgendetwas tun
und die menschen vor allem in dem
grenzgebiet der verlangen von der
polizei und von der politik tatsächlich
auch etwas zu machen es ist ja kein ganz
neues problem paul warum reagiert die
bundesregierung erst jetzt warum hat man
das bislang einfach nur gesehen und
nichts gemacht man hat das gefühl dass
die bundesregierung insbesondere beim
thema migration erstmal ganz lange nicht
hinschaut und überlegt was man tun
könnte weil das ist ja ein unangenehmes
problem und wenn man das anspricht dann
braucht es taten tatsächlich du hast
vollkommen recht gibt es diese zahlen
bild hat das erste mal im sommer oder
frühsommer darüber berichtet wie lukas
schenkel flüchtlinge einfliegen lässt
sozusagen und dann über die grenze
bringt richtung polen dass das problem
zunimmt bis jetzt hat niemand lukas
schinko direkt adressiert bis jetzt hat
niemand wirklich sanktionen gefordert
und bis jetzt hat auch niemand über
grenzkontrollen gesprochen und das zeigt
schon ein bisschen dass die politik
vielleicht beim thema migration nicht so
ganz genau hinschauen will weil man die
sorge hat insbesondere vor dem wahlkampf
dass man da ja ein thema ein fass
aufmacht was vielleicht der afg helfen
könnte nur das ist ein trugschluss ich
glaube die afd und die frage so zu sagen
welche wählerinnen und wähler für welche
partei dann stimmen bei der frage von
sicherheit von migration da muss das
thema ganz klar adressiert werden und
das hat die union auch im wahlkampf
verpasst das hat auch horst seehofer
verpasst im wahlkampf irgendwie zu
adressieren das war ja ohnehin in den
letzten monaten ja fast jahren ein
minister auf abruf auch in eine tree
allen und duellen die es gab ein thema
das nie so richtig angesprochen wurde
ihr habt es gestern abend hier bei uns
bei bild live angesprochen bei viertel
nach acht dem bild live talk und
stichwort polen wir schauen mal kurz
rein
die polnische regierung nutzt diese
gelegenheit nicht wie schamlos aus
frontex darf nicht da oder begrenzt ist
raten dürfen dann nicht hin die
beobachter werden nur vereinzelt hin
gelassen und was wollen die polen mache
ich sagen wir bauen eine mauer jetzt
bild detmold york rangers tot erfolg das
sagen sie nicht aber es kommt
wahrscheinlich als nächstes also sie
wollen eine mauer bauen ähnlich wie das
mit großem beifall
hier viktor orban gemacht hat in ungarn
und erhoffen sich die gleichen die
gleichen positiven effekte für ihre
komische regierung da die immer weiter
sich von der eu entfernt und nutzt es
auch politisch in dieser haben hier
schaut bei zu die eu die sie nicht ins
land lassen mit den grenztruppen die tut
nix aber wir wir bauen die mauer und wir
helfen euch euch abzuschotten uns
abschotten von denen die da kommen weil
die eu die toten nicht sagt béla anda
das ist ja nun mal fakt sie schaut
einfach nur zu sie lässt lukaschenko
gewähren sie lässt polen gewähren was
erwartest du jetzt von der
bundesregierung ich erwarte von der
neuen bundesregierung insbesondere denn
die alte hits ja kaum noch so richtig im
amt hat man das gefühl zwar versucht
heiko maas jetzt sanktionen
durchzudrücken und all diese dinge aber
ich erwarte insbesondere von der neuen
bundesregierung dass sie in europa eine
koalition form der willigen die
tatsächlich etwas tut gegen lukas
schinko da muss man dann mit wladimir
putin ins gericht gehen da muss man bei
dem putin dem russischen präsidenten
druck machen denn nur er sorgt dafür
dass lukaschenko weiterhin so mächtig
ist und dann zweitens und das ist
richtig was horst seehofer sagen muss
ist in besonderen fällen diese
grenzkontrollen geben damit wir auch
zeigen wir lassen das nicht einfach zu
also wir lassen nicht einfach diejenigen
gewähren wir lassen nicht lukaschenka
bestimmen wie viele flüchtlinge zu uns
nach deutschland kommen wir lassen die
nicht einfach über die grenze laufen
weil die polen sie durch lassen sondern
wir bestimmen selbst was an unseren
grenzen passiert und wie viele
flüchtlinge wie aufnehmen können wir
lassen uns auch nicht erpressen absolut
[Musik]